Joe really was an amazing person I mean
she lived just just over there on a boat
and she loved being an MP everyone who
met her on his good things to say about
her at and it becomes when somebody
passes away you say nice things about
them and it can sometimes lose the
impact when it's always been said about
people passed away but with Joe she
really was an amazing person a brilliant
politician a great campaigner a decent
human being a three-dimensional person
full of life who just love being an MP
in Parliament she was only an MP for a
year what is it that she achieved how
did she manage to have such impact in
such a short amount of time in
Parliament you know she was basically a
local girl from that area who'd done
well and you know gave of a great job
because she had the chance to be the MP
for that area and that love for the job
of that passion Sean through not we
started how successful she was when she
first decided to run to be the candidate
for that area she needed reassurance
that she could be a decent candidate and
a good MP and she was a great candidate
who won and was a great MP and she went
about being an MP without pomposity with
our arrogance making friends
straightaway holding the Prime
Minister's account but at the same time
not being scared to make friends with a
former secretary state for in touch
development because it makes you could
help the refugees in Syria calling out
wrong when ron was happening and a
really nice really really nice person
and what did she achieve for the for the
refugees and george osborne said just
last night that she actually helped
change government policy which is quite
something for a new backbench MP oh I
remember her asking questions at PMQs
that place is a bear pit
and when you're an opposition MP there
are 350 MPs on the other side Bain you
down and when she spoke because everyone
knew she was a serious politician about
to make a serious point there was a sort
of hush and remember holding the Prime
Minister to account in relation to his
views on what's happening to the
refugees and asylum seekers she managed
to persuade the government to change
policy in relation to those we took from
that part of the world in one year
achieved more then many of my colleagues
I say with the respect for him achieving
1050 20 years in that place the idea
that she met having served and tried to
help livelihoods in some of the most
dangerous parts of the world that she
met had death in her own home town in
such a horrible way first of all she
loved being an MP and you know it's just
worth saying their game then again she
loved being MP part and parcel if you're
if you're an excellent MP like she was
was to engage the situation to meet with
them and that's what kept her anchor
anchored that's what meant that we
should went around Parliament's she
didn't of years and graces no pomposity
not spending time you know socializing
with Westminster village but actually
regularly going back to efficiency
speech defect situates so she knew what
the important issues were one of the
phrases she used in a maiden speech who
got more in common than divide us and
she had a wicked sense of humor you know
remember always teasing her about how
she lives on a boat isn't it cold and
she was would invite me down to the bone
see for myself and stuff but you know
she was lovely person and it's tragic
it's where heartbroken what do you think
it says about politics right now in this
referendum campaign do you think there's
a poisonous backdrop from this
referendum campaign you know I think the
way we conduct politics can inspire
people can put people off can lead to a
poisonous environment and I think the
way politics is conducting this country
is poisonous that's not the best of
politics and Joe was the best of
politics she inspired people she
energized people she infused people she
called things out when they were wrong
and I think we should all reflect in the
way the referendum campaign has been
conducted